[Music]
this week on
forward listen I I have nothing against
Joe personally and I will vote for him
if Trump is the nominee but I would love
to see someone new come along from
either party I think our parties are
broken and we can see from polling that
most people agree of the you know
thousands of Republican voters that
braved the cold 40% chose someone else
and that's
meaningful um unless that number remains
split between two
[Music]
people it is my genuine pleasure to
Welcome to the podcast political
commentator for CNN and columnist just
about everywhere you might know her from
billar Essie cup welcome Essie thanks
for having me so nice to be here yeah
such a pleasure so uh I was thinking who
could talk sense about American politics
to folks let people know how they should
be interacting with the with the news
and you were the top of the list who is
that person yeah I know indeed indeed so
this conversation is happening after the
Iowa caucus and right before New
Hampshire votes it's going to be super
timely so what was your reaction to uh
the results in Iowa I had a few um
first and foremost I was eager to see
whether the polls were under indexing
Trump or over indexing him and you know
turns out they were about right um again
that's a snapshot in time that's not a
prescription or or you know looking
looking down the road but I was
interested and they were right about
Trump's commanding lead in Iowa he's
very popular there however of the you
know thousands of Republican voters that
braved the cold to go and caucus that
night 40% chose someone else and that's
meaningful um unless that number remains
split between two people then it's
meaningless but it's meaningful that 40%
of Republicans in Iowa this very red
magga State very Evangelical State chose
someone else so what that says to me is
going forward there is an opportunity
for a trump alternative to emerge if
they can kind of get out of each other's
way I I don't think that person will
emerge if Nikki Haley and Ronda santis
keep splitting the vote hey Essie I'm
gonna tell you a funny story from four
years ago check it out so I'm running
for president in Iowa and then someone
interviews me is like hey you're at 5%
of the polls and then uh I respond oh
polls scholes they're undercounting all
of the enthusiasm that we're seeing a
lot of our people are going to be new
and then we got 5%
they were right
on yeah and and that a Selzer poll in
Iowa is very very
accurate right and was pretty much
spoton New Hampshire is a different
story I have to say that the polling in
New Hampshire is dicier in my opinion
because a significant part of the
electorate let's call it
36% is independent yeah I think it it's
not insane to Target registered
Republicans and Democrats but it's a
little trickier just to to Target
Independents who can opt for one primary
or the other and as an example of what
I'm I mean about 110,000 Republicans
caucused in Iowa last week and it's a
state of three million so you're talking
about fewer than 4% of ioans showed up
for this thing and by the way when I ran
for president as a Democrat last time uh
my win number was about 40,000 was the
thought um which is about what the
winner got I think they like Bernie
might have gotten 41,000 or something
like that so we're talking about
relatively modest numbers uh if you just
walked into an Iowa Diner um the number
of people that were actually going to
caucus probably pretty low just like
walk into a random place but then if you
walk to a convening of party activists
then the density is higher now New
Hampshire it's easier because it's a
primary people can roll out of bed and
vote
and and so the total number of of votes
in New Hampshire will be in the multiple
hundreds of thousands and the
conventional wisdom
is that the uh The Independents are
going to Pile in to the Republican
primary and vote for a Nikki haly uh
that that's the big theory of the case
uh what do you think yeah that's
certainly her hope and look I know New
Hampshire really well I grew up in
Massachusetts went to school right on
the border I know
New Hampshire voters and they're weird I
mean that in a very you know positive
way they're very independent they don't
like to be told who to vote for they
like to wait till the last minute and as
you said it's a primary so they can do
it any you know any time of the day it
doesn't take five hours like a caucus
can and so you don't know until you know
and you have that exit polling in terms
of knowing why but yeah I can see Nikki
Haley doing very well in New Hampshire I
can also see Donald Trump doing very
well I was just up there a couple weeks
ago for um a family event and there were
loads of trump signs again snapshot in
time and certainly anecdotal evidence
I'm pretty sure those signs are still up
they're still there and and yeah I mean
it's there are pockets of New Hampshire
big Pockets um that are Trump country
and so I'm not sure she can beat him
there but I think she'll have a very
good showing I know it's not Ronda
Santa's country it really isn't um so I
don't think he's going to do well there
and he doesn't either hey I've got a a
quick um Insider question for you so
you're on TV all the time you can ask
your opinion um and there's what you
think will happen and what you want to
happen I'll give you an example from
myself right now uh I think Trump's
rolling through this process uh and is
going to up the Republican nominee very
quickly maybe even as soon as uh
February or even you know
earlier it's it's very possible yeah um
now I don't like that outcome so if
someone sticks a camera on me and is
like what what are you gonna do then you
know I say oh like Nikki Hy has a path
has a shot and then I make a case
sometimes um if you know because you
know like I clearly don't want to just
concede in this case like a bad outcome
um does that happen
you yeah because listen you have to be
honest about the fact that the media
plays a role in this and you know we saw
that caucus night when multiple networks
including my own called it before the
votes were even cast in some cases so
when you're asked on
television um you have an opportunity to
kind of you know it's I'm opinion so I
get to do this reporter should not do
this but I'm an opinion commentator you
have an opportunity yeah yeah yeah
imagine me trying to keep this shut um
so you know I have the opportunity to
say look I think Nikki hilly has a
pathway and I believe that but I like
you also believe Trump feels very
inevitable and when I'm talking to
friends and family off camera I say I
think he's got the nomination locked up
but you have a role to play in the
political conversation and you know it
isn't a lie it isn't even a wish it's
I'm going to stand up for a person that
I think would be better than Trump and
and could get there and if other people
are persuaded by that argument because I
lay out all the wise and all the uh the
reasons why she should that can have an
impact and that's why that's why we're
hired um you know opinion folks on all
sides of the political Spectrum are
hired to do just that to to persuade to
change Minds to provoke thought that's
that's our job what a fun job you have
Essie to try and push people or persuade
people in a certain direction I mean it
is except you feel like especially in
this political climate I'm sure you feel
this way too that you're screaming into
an into a a void into a vacuum because
you know I've been screaming about Trump
since 2015 and how terrible he will be
for the Republican party and not only
did you know my party's voters ignore me
but people I thought were much more
principled inside the party also ignored
everything we were saying so that's not
fun this podcast is sponsored by
expressvpn when you go to the bathroom
you always close the door behind you
because you don't want random people
seeing what you're doing but when you go
online people sometimes can see what
you're doing I'm talking about those big
tech companies and other folks who might
not have your best interest at heart
that's why I use expressvpn and you
should too this way your data stays
yours it can't be sold and resold when I
use expressvpn you just click one button
transports you to another server and
also give you access to fun content that
might be available in another country
it's like you're a global traveler
without ever leaving your home get an
extra 3 months of expressvpn free by
going to expressvpn.com
yangang that's
EXs vpn.com yangang for three extra
months free expressvpn.com
[Music]
yangang yeah and and there's really no
excuse this time like the first time
You' be like oh you know like maybe
it'll uh outperform and then now this
time it's like whoa you kind of know
what you're getting so anyone who is on
board this time um really is on the
wrong side of History so here's another
example of get asked think something
wish for the other um looking at the
numbers I think Trump beats Biden in the
general if it's held today uh you know
and just some basic numbers out there uh
Joe Biden's walking around with a 38%
approval rating uh he's going to be 82
at the end of this year he's down in um
five of the six swing States and
according to recent polling including by
eight in Michigan which he won eight in
Georgia which he won right uh nine in
North Carolina which they're hoping to
contest and he only lost by one last
time um so it's like that the numbers
have all
moved to the wrong direction by eight uh
and they spent 25 million trying to
boost his numbers in the swing on an ad
campaign about bics was a total bust uh
and so I look at this and be like guys
this is um this
bad like this yeah now you know if it
came down to it I think anyone would
guess you know I would vastly prefer
Biden to Trump and so if you wind up in
the situation where you know like I'm
having to uh try and get people to to
vote in a particular direction you know
I I would pick Biden 100 times out of
100 um but but I think Biden is heading
towards an L if we wind up with that
general election
matchup I completely agree and it's very
frustrating because when I talk to Biden
folks and other Democrats it's almost
like fingers in the ears like they don't
want to hear it and they are really
convinced yeah that um
that that fan bargain is what it's going
to come down to well if I have to choose
I'm going to choose Biden but I I think
that's very dangerous and
honestly I think they're counting on
they're counting on row which was really
effective in the midterms and they're
not wrong to do that they're counting on
the Democracy argument which was also
effective in the midterms they're not
wrong to do that but what they're
under valuing is what's happening on the
border and the way people feel about the
economy and you know telling people what
they feel is wrong is a very bad idea in
politics and the Border stuff is really
bad and I wrote a kind of whimsical
column A a week or so ago that if Biden
wanted to turn all of this around and
shake things up he should close the
border he should call an a state of
emergency at the Border close it
Republicans would freak out because he's
taking away their number one talking
point Democrats would freak out because
obviously they want the Border open and
it would force Congress to finally come
to the table and figure it out um
I think that could actually really jolt
his campaign now I know he won't do that
but the Border stuff is really leading a
lot of the
political um angst and it's what drove
Iowa caucus go goers to Trump I mean we
have that exit polling immigration was
the number one wow issue for them they
are not on the border but they are
feeling it because when you live in a
state like New York and they're moving
your kids out of public school to put
migrants in on a cold day well this
affects you as a family and you think
why this isn't fair this isn't working
even with the compassion for everyone
involved this isn't working and so I
think that's going to be their
biggest um Albatross if if Biden loses
it will be because of the Border you
know some of the recent polling SE has
Biden losing among Latinos to Trump you
know you know I mean
things that uh de Democrats um wouldn't
uh Envision and one of the frustrating
things when when I also talk to
Democrats who also have that kind of
like head in the sand or like you know
fingers in the ears approach is like
look it's not what you think it's not
what I think it's what a
100,000 uh swing voters in Nevada
Arizona Michigan Georgia um Wisconsin
think a lot of them are not College
grads
and one of the the things I saw in a
focus group run by a friend of our Sarah
Longwell um where there there was
someone who voted for Biden who says
he's going to vote for Trump this time
and says I'm just going to ignore the
news and enjoy the economy uh where like
if you go to the the person be like but
but democracy is on the line he's like
yeah look I don't I don't care about
your democracy I'm just going to turn
off the talking heads and just like en
enjoy my
uh you know like presumably like lower
inflation better numbers Etc I mean you
only need uh 50,000 folks uh uh who make
a similar rationalization in your mind
and Trump wins yes that's a really
interesting quote and I'll probably I
will probably quote it at some point
because that's I mean that is it and the
Democracy argument it matters to us but
we have the luxury of caring about
democracy right I'm sitting here very
nice house in Connecticut right I'm in
my I'm in my home studio my kids at a
great school I'm not worried about crime
I'm not worried about opioids in my town
I'm not worried about illegal
immigration running through my town I
I'm lucky I can care about democracy if
you're someone who's living in a big
city or a rural Town that's ravaged by
drugs or or crime or illegal immigrants
that you think are taking your jobs or
your you know your resources is you
don't care about you don't care about
democracy care about your gas prices you
care about your food prices you care
about the job that you haven't gotten a
raise at in five years so you have to
connect with voters on all of these
metrics and I think the there's a real
blind spot for for Biden on the economy
and immigration he's just not making
that connection with a lot of people oh
yeah he's um behind Trump by 25 points
on the economy among Independents I mean
you know like you see numbers like that
and you're like okay guys I think I see
what your problem's going to be
yeah how are you going to get healthier
this year one way to do so is have
healthy chef-crafted meals delivered to
your door stressfree what the heck am I
talking about Factor Factor's 2-minute
meals are your secret weapon to a
healthier happier you I've been eating
factor for this last number of weeks and
wow it's been a game Cher we're talking
about delicious chicken taco bowl spicy
pablano beef and every time I'm like ooh
this is going to be tasty and it is
makes you feel good it's cost efficient
it's flexible no prep no mess you can't
screw it up just poke a couple holes in
it heat it up and it's fresh never
Frozen I got to say if you try Factor
you are going to be pumped it's going to
make you healthier happier more
productive in the New Year T to factor
meals.com
y50 and use code y50 to get 50% off
that's code y50 at factor meals.com
y50 to get 50% off
Factor
by the time this conversation airs I
will have endorsed a guy named Dean
Phillips who's running for president
against uh Joe Biden uh it's why I'm I'm
gonna be in New Hampshire it's going to
be good fun uh and and here's the dean
Phillips theory of the case so Dean
Phillips is third term member of
Congress from a purple District in
Minnesota so he's like a pretty
reasonable guy uh and then he looks up
and like hey guys I think Joe's going to
lose uh and we should probably do
something about that U polling shows
that a generic Democrat defeats Trump by
six or eight points uh where where Biden
loses by let's call it three or four uh
and so that's like a nine or 10o swing
uh you know Joe Biden said himself there
are 50 Democrats who could defeat Donald
Trump why not just upgrade the nominee
to someone who's a sub
octogenarian uh
and and by the way the same thing works
in Reverse too like if Nikki Haley were
to become the Republican nominee I think
she cleans Joe Biden's clock you know by
yeah whatever I mean there was one poll
that had it like 17 it might not be that
gargantuan but I think it would be a
very clean win um and the Democrats
still have every opportunity to uh
similarly upgrade their nominee now uh
in New Hampshire and most people think
well this thing is baked because you
know Joe's got it in the bag but you
know what's going on in New Hampshire
where Joe's not on the ballot because
they're punishing New Hampshire for
going out of order so you have Dean
Phillips who polling shows that 28% um
up from zero uh you know 10 weeks ago so
he's Rising fast uh just like a lot of
other states New Hampshire Democrats are
also kind of uneasy about uh Joe and his
age Joe actually has done poorly there
three out of three times and so if Dean
Phillips puts up a big number anything
starting with a three handle for example
it it would
be I mean like 20% plus is like a rebuke
like 30% plus would be like you know an
equivalent of like throwing the
over on an incumbent president and then
the party would have to look at it and
say wait a minute you know what what
just happened um and then uh Dean would
have this huge head of steam and there
would be a genuine contest where people
would draw some of the same conclusions
I just outlined um so that's the dean
Phillips theory of the case and I will
say also the Andrew Yang theory of the
case yeah sounds
familiar yeah yeah so
uh what are your thoughts on the the
dean Phillips effort well let me start
ecumenically and say I I've been telling
Democrats who would listen for years
that they need to build a a younger
bench and that was true in Congress I
was supportive of Tim Ryan's effort to
to S of you know push Nancy Pelosi aside
and get some younger blood into
Democratic Leadership because not only
is it necessary inside the party but
then you grow a bench and you condition
Democratic voters to see new people they
haven't seen a new face in
Forever you know not since Barack Obama
came along you know they they really
just like to keep putting the same
people into these positions so
ecumenically I love this I love wait
let's summarize
Barack Hillary Joe Joe yeah you're right
yeah yeah and listen before Trump we did
the same thing we decided who was going
to be the next nominee at the last
election right like whose turn was it
who came in second we'll put them up and
so we didn't you know we didn't give
voters a a a a chance to um you know
find new Talent really either so that's
that's ecumenically I love this um
idea you know
practically it's a long shot I'm sure
you know this and and um I'm sure I
haven't met Dean Phillips I I might have
I might have interviewed him at some
point um he seems lovely and really
smart and I I like his brand of of
politics and I think he could do well in
New Hampshire but it's really hard to go
against an incumbent you know this um
because you have the full weight and
resources of the DNC or the RNC behind
you it's just really hard to sort of
jostle that you know infrastructure
loose and cut through it but listen I I
have nothing against Joe personally and
I will vote for him if Trump is the
nominee but I would love to see someone
new come along from either party I think
our parties are broken and we can see
from polling that most people agree
about 65% of Americans do not feel
aligned with either of the two parties
and that's because they're in the middle
on almost every issue the parties like
to talk in extremes and so you can feel
very unrepresented if you are in the
middle in fact the majority uh on lots
of issues from abortion to immigration
to guns to climate if you're in the
middle you feel orphaned by your party
because you're not pure enough you're
not you're not you know loyal enough um
that's very I think um disorienting for
a lot of Voters and they're deeply
deeply disillusioned with our two
parties and they don't want either of
these guys they don't want to make this
Choice yeah the Biden Trump rematch is
unappealing to three out of four
Americans or something ridiculous uh and
and it really puts the dysfunction of
the parties in Stark relief uh I'm with
you on trying to upgrade generationally
um I I also agree you know the party um
has it out for you uh it's tough um so
with with Dean's campaign let's say he
puts up a big number in New Hampshire
and then the Press looks at it and it's
like wow like that that because I think
even people who are very deeply in the
know would be shocked and stunned if
Dean put up 25% or whatever the number
is uh uh and then uh the question is
whether you get a genuine horse race
Dynamic um South Carolina happens um 10
days later it'd be tough um but Michigan
Michigan is at the end of February and
that could be a real contest especially
because there's a lot of discontent with
Joe uh in Michigan uh in in various
quarters but do you worry that let's say
he does as well in New Hampshire do you
worry that Biden and plenty of folks in
the media will just say well Biden
wasn't there he wasn't on the
ballot yeah I mean they're going to try
and minimize the impact of the loss for
sure um but you are looking at an
environment where the incumbent
president traditionally will get you
know 85 90% um with zero effort at all
yeah and you also have an historical
precedent of I think it was Hubert
Humphrey challenging uh LBJ and getting
42 2% in New Hampshire and then LBJ said
I'm
out afterwards um so there's this whole
range I mean gosh if Dean were to get
42% uh everyone would look at that and
say I mean like like this is a
repudiation of the Biden plan um and I
do think the Biden plan is a terrible
plan I think that as in the running
Biden I don't I'm not talking about a
specific policy I'm the Biden plan to
run for re-election the second time I
mean if he were to do a George
Washington and say Hey I'm I'm I'm out
time to pass the torch to the Next
Generation he would go down in the books
as one of the
greats Trump gets a lot of uh great
things done is a voice of reason on the
world stage and then steps aside of the
Next Generation that's like check check
check as it is instead it's going to be
overstay welcome uh in like serve the
country back to Trump uh you know on a
platter um and then bemoan the end of
democracy I
mean that that that's where we're
heading in my estimation he's sort of
Brett faving it right I mean overstaying
a little bit too much for that last
season with the Jets which didn't really
work out um and this was so unnecessary
because he was elected to be a
transitional he even called himself I'm
gonna be a bridge to the Next Generation
and my my joke SE was like right bridge
to the next generation is not cling to
office until you expire at the age of '
86 I mean that's nuts exactly and yeah
the there should be no embarrassment
among Democrats that they want to move
on from Joe Biden the idea was him for
him to get out get Trump out get some
sanity restored which he did check check
check and then yeah leave it to the next
Democrat in line of of your choosing
right so there should be no
embarrassment about that but they are so
unwilling to admit that it's his time to
go and move on they won't do it they
can't do it and it might end up you know
handing the country back over to
TR hey YouTube thanks for watching
please do hit like And subscribe and hit
that Bell if you want to be notified
every time a new episode drops probably
on Mondays but hit that Bell and thank
you so you know how I have beef with I
have beef with a lot of
people
but I I I I have beef with Gavin Nome
Gretchen Whitmer JB pritzker and all the
campaigns and waiting who were told sit
this one out and wait till 28 I mean if
Trump wins what the heck does 28 even
look like you know what I mean I feel
like those characters are missing their
Moment Like This is their moment the
country needs them they should run yeah
uh and if they ran then I think uh even
Joe and Jamie wouldn't be able to hold a
real real competition well those are
recognizable names you know and again no
offense to Dean like they're more
recognizable than Dean they're just you
know these are Governors and so they've
I think had a bit more
exposure um and so yeah I think they
would have been well positioned but you
don't cut in line over there and you
know that was true of Pelosi you know
stenny Hoyer has been waiting for that
job for a long time bless his heart um
and you just you don't you don't um you
don't cut the line and it's seen as you
know ungrateful or or whatever it is but
for the all the Seth moltons and the
Eric swall Wells and the Tim Ryan young
Democrats that I really like that I
think are charismatic talented
thoughtful smart kind decent there's a a
bunch of great options over on the left
and it's like they're trying to shoot
themselves in the foot with this it's
it's a bit it's a bit of a cannibalism
kind of mentality over there it's not
good for the party it's definitely not
good for the country yeah I I call it
Conformity and careerism where
everyone's just like yeah I'll stay in
line because if I I stand up and be like
hey guys Joe's old B you know bored at
42 or whatever then then you'll be
pillared by the way that's how the
entire Dean Phillips campaign started is
that he raised his hand and said I I
don't think Joe should run again and
then everyone um attacked him and the
Press he's like you guys just said the
same thing to me in private what the
heck is going on you all you all
agree yeah that but and then Dean tried
to recruit Gavin new gret Whitmer and JB
priter and they wouldn't take his call
and and he jokingly said he's like they
would take my call under any other
circumstances but when I was calling to
talk about this they were like oh
unavailable unavailable and and Dean's
you know like Vice chair of the party
again third term member of Congress
flipped a a a purple District like I
mean he's like a dude you know what I
mean
the the fact that they were like you
know cannot can cannot uh even take a
call with can't be seen talking to you
yeah yeah it's really it's a sh it's a
shame but again there's I think a lot of
myopia in in politics but especially in
the Democratic party like we've got
there's this protectionism going on for
you know the the old guard it's really
um it's counterproductive and I think
that's going to play out big time this
year well hey if if I'm right that Dean
ends up uh catalyzing a real primary um
it sounds like you and I would be happy
about it um yeah do you do you have any
guidance for people who are watching the
news as to um what they should be trying
to keep an eye out for on Tuesday uh the
night of the New Hampshire primaries
well I think the the margin between
Trump and Nikki is going to be the story
I mean if she beats him that's huge
momentum for her going into South
Carolina and it really pierces the
inevitability idea that that he's
pushing and that you and I agree it
probably is real um you know she can win
in a in a state she can beat him
somewhere then that argument kind of
slips away a little bit and maybe only
temporarily but it Slips Away a little
bit so that'll be a huge story if if she
wins um if she comes in second whether
it's close or not I I I think like you
said he's going to wrap it up real quick
probably even uh more quickly than a lot
of people are imagining probably before
super Tuesday yeah uh well I mean
there's even some speculation that uh
Nikki U might not want to bring it to
South Carolina where she's theoretically
uh strong because she was the governor
there but that electorat is actually not
as good a fit for her versus Trump as
New Hampshire which has like a higher
education level higher independent level
the governor is a never Trump Republican
like if she doesn't beat him in New
Hampshire it's hard to see another state
that's a better opportunity that's
exactly what it is and I've been saying
this is the the battle between Nikki and
Ronda santis is a battle between money
and map um Ron's running out of money
he's actually better positioned in
States down the road than Nikki Haley is
for the reasons you just said um where
there are fewer moderates in
Independents but can he last till those
States come up with with you know his
dwindling funds can he convince donors
to keep giving him money to get that far
her problem is the map you know she does
real well upfront but Beyond New
Hampshire and South Carolina it gets
real tough for her so it's this how far
can one go and how long can the other go
is the sort of the the crisis that
they're
facing
this podcast is sponsored by Helix sleep
it's a new year time to make yourself
better rested more energized and a great
way to do that is with a helix sleep
mattress I took their quiz and I said
you know what I roll around a lot I
sleep in my back I need a lot of support
and I got matched with a dawn Lux
mattress that has become a game changer
not just for me but for my kids it's
their favorite mattress even though it
wasn't designed for them Helix will now
actually tailor mattresses specifically
for Big and Tall customers and for kids
they have a 100 night trial you can try
the mattress for 3 months send it back
and a 10 to 15-year warranty it's the
top rated Mattress By wired and many
other Publications don't take my word
for it try it out for yourself Helix is
offering 20% off all mattress orders and
two free pillows for our listeners go to
Helix sleep /y Yang and use code Helix
partner2 this is their best offer yet
and it won't last long with Helix better
sleep starts
[Music]
now and on the Democratic side what kind
of number do you think Dean has to put
up for pundits to be like whoa like I
didn't see that coming this might be a
thing yeah I I agree with you 30s 30s
would be an
undeniable kind of shock right and you'd
have to if you're a Democrat you'd have
to look at that pretty seriously again I
think folks are going to say well B
Biden wasn't there but that's a that
would be a huge number because they
don't have to go and and and vote for
anyone they don't have to go and vote
for Dean Phillips uh you know just
because Biden's off the ballot they
could stay home they could also vote in
the Republican primary um so uh I think
that would be a good number can that can
that snowball and and get that momentum
we'll have to see Beyond New Hampshire
but you know I like it I'm here for it
for sure I like that as a threshold SC
30 yeah shoot for 30% you're right that
that has a nice ring to it it is
undeniable yeah um yeah so uh you know
if someone's watching this uh before
Tuesday call your friends in New
Hampshire and say hey check out this
Dean Phillips guy if he gets 30% weird
let's make it we might have a non octen
Arian out there on the trail 54 Co
talente gelato delightful you love the
jars you love the containers love it
even more in the White House gelato for
all Universal basic
gelato it's actually better than
Universal basic gelato it's like
comprehensive gelato reform yeah I mean
it's premium premium gelato for all um
per well Essie your voice of reason and
wisdom always how can people keep up
with you uh and your work I'm so sick of
myself I'm on CNN all the time now um
you know because it's finally an
election year so you can see me on CNN
but you can also read my um nationally
syndicated column in the New York daily
news or papers around the country and um
I pop up kind of everywhere it's
annoying you don't have to look too hard
to find me SE is easy to find for good
reason hopefully we'll have some things
to to celebrate um yeah good luck I'll
be I'll be I'll be rooting for you guys
for sure well appreciate the heck out of
you and uh and I'll see you on set at
some point uh when I'm when I'm there
hopefully uh you know like bearing some
good news yeah I'll I'll catch you in
the Green
[Music]
Room